las granjas de cannabis son habituales
en la costa oeste de Estados Unidos
esta en Washington es una de las más de
1000 que existen solo en este estado
junto con Colorado Washington fue el
primer estado en legalizar la marihuana
en el país Oregón hizo lo propio tres
años después durante un tiempo los
cultivadores de marihuana Tuvieron mucho
éxito pero ahora ven como su negocio se
esfuma en medio de un mercado
sobresaturado Isaac Foster es el
fundador de un mercado de Cannabis en
Portland dice tener claro cómo funcionan
sus debilidades
el exceso de oferta Yo diría que es la
palabra clave para definir el mercado de
Cannabis en Oregón este estado es un
maravilloso experimento porque a
diferencia de otros estados tenía un
sistema de licencias básicamente
ilimitadas que alentó a un gran número
de personas a cultivar
la imposibilidad de vender cualquier
excedente es otro problema se queda
Atrapado dentro de Fronteras del Estado
debido a la prohibición Federal de la
marihuana algunos mantienen la esperanza
de que la administración del presidente
Joe biden apruebe el comercio de
marihuana entre los estados que la han
regulado estamos aquí sentados en una
especie de ralentí de nuestra capacidad
Si se quiere a la espera de que nuestras
leyes cambien para que podamos
posicionarnos para jugar Ya sabes para
participar en el mercado en general pero
algunos cultivadores no encuentran
solución a la vista y se las arreglan
mientras pueden
Y si la estoy vendiendo ahora voy a
tener pérdidas pero ya sabes tienes que
saber cuando hay pérdida
21 estados ya han legalizado el uso
recreativo del Cannabis en el país las
ventas combinadas de cannabis medicinal
y recreativo en Estados Unidos podrían
alcanzar los
33.600 millones de dólares a final de
2023 y más de 50.000 millones en solo
cinco años